[Music]
in too much sharing news submitted by
Lauren from Maryland with an exclamation
mark yay
Tyreese puts all his business on social
media then makes an apparently false
claim that Will and Jada gave him five
million dollars oh Tyrese dude I [ __ ]
love this but I hate it at the same time
wait he lied about well I want to hear
your best Tyrese impression I was I was
going more for the singing Tyrese no
come on later yeah but this dude just
remember what with him and Snoop Dogg
I'm hungry
that's the only thing ya know you always
eating buddy I will say this though
Tyrese done lost his [ __ ] mind
why what happened
seems like it so what's happening right
now is he's been in legal battles with
his ex-wife
over their ten-year-old daughter now the
ex Shayla she was claiming that Tyrese
had beaten their daughter and he put
like his knee on her back and held her
hands with one hand and then beat her
with the other and that it got so bad
that the daughter couldn't even sit how
old is it I think they were just
watching an MMA fight and they wanted to
copy the moves and is that bad this is
my dad always put my hands behind my
back yes you were abused as a child so
yeah that's the entire reason what I do
not those normal it's not yeah so then
he ended up posting like he's been very
vocal on his social media accounts and
now people are thinking that he just had
like a really public breakdown because
he posted this really long video on his
Facebook just crying and saying how like
he hasn't seen his girl I will tell you
this though man it was really so this is
my first thing as a comedian I laugh my
ass off yeah second I watched it the
okay now second thought maybe like six
time and after the sixth one I started
feeling human and I was like damn it's
weird that in Hollywood how come like
actors turn out that way you know what
I'm saying like there has to be
something about that industry that makes
you turn into that
because at first it was hilarious
because you see this dude that played
you know of role that Tupac was supposed
to play a baby boy you know I mean he
would be the hood strong man he always
gives life advice all of a sudden he
comes out in the most worst way possible
people saying you're being very
vulnerable but at the same time it's
like you're not because you're using the
social media platform to gain sympathy
from a bunch of random people you know I
need you sitting there like it's like
and he's just like scream I'll show you
guys the clip right now video
Sheila's his daughter's name by the way
yeah so you listen this is all I got
don't take my baby okay is this a joke
I'm not doing anything illegal but I
don't want nobody oh my god am i doing
something illegal by doing this video or
is this am i protected by the First
Amendment oh the amendment
don't take my baby I'm at $13,000 a
month what more do you want from me
that's a lot of money he's already
giving $30 a month thirteen thousand on
legal fees but then there's other
reports saying that that's how much he's
giving I don't know that's a lot of
money looks broken yeah see how some of
that appears because he's like the good
seniors actor and I grew up on him
watching him and stuff and I'm just like
so confused I don't know if it was
supposed to be funny cuz it seems like a
genius fun is really up okay so if it is
real it's just interesting that like in
this moment of crisis he's still not
still knew how to do a plug real quick
something that's the part that's funny
to me but you know what's the oddest
thing too so he's being he is in this
situation per se because the his ex-wife
is saying that he is an unfit father
this does not prove that you are fit you
don't have it she's actually using this
video of course it's so counterintuitive
and that's what I'm saying it's like
what the [ __ ] would you think he's not
in a great stable yeah he's not scary so
she's using that video against them yeah
it seems like she's also saying that
like she's using that saying like you
see here's proof he's not fable yeah so
then here's a photo of his daughter and
his he has perfect teeth and here they
are again and so he ended up posting
that first video right he was in that
Facebook video as well he was saying
like I have so many rich millionaire
billionaire friends and I'm always there
for you guys but no one's coming through
for me and like hands up saying things
like that
I should make me laugh so hard because
he started saying names and I followed
his friend be like this [ __ ]
busy making those sci-fi films what
about helping me out with my child
support oh yeah so then he had the
posting this on Instagram oh no he says
when we show up for each other there's
nothing that can't be done I repeat
nothing my wife kept the news away from
me cuz I've been on with lawyers all day
but our family and our sister Jada
pinkett-smith and my brother Will Smith
just sent us five million dollars to
help keep us afloat you guys asked me to
get off and stay off the internet now
that my daughter's legal fees will be
paid we'll listen
ellipses the Smiths and their whole
family has always shown up for the
Gibson's Uncle Will you're an uncle for
real and I'm saying again if you guys
are out there in the Atlanta area please
vote but yeah it was hilarious because
he was saying that Will and Jada gave
him five million dollars to stay off the
internet and he posts about it well I
thought it sounded like they'd given
five million dollars to help with the
child support and legal fees if they
wanted him to stay off it
oh because he's probably looking back
but asked me to get off and stay off the
inner
God like stop digging your own grave
here's five million don't make things
worse
that's what Tyrese is claiming so then
he posted like a little bunch of photos
with him and Will and Jada and they were
that close friends and then like you
never know actors Jada pinkett-smith oh
my god you were on the phone for more
than 30 minutes but see that's what I'm
saying this what are you doing that's
why I'm saying like this is not normal
you know what I mean like it's so it's
so disgusting to me it do you see what
I'm saying like you can't even grieve or
you can't even deal with your problems
without getting publicity from yeah
that's how Saturday yeah that's how much
he misses the limelight no that's what
it is like in you but but like they just
had a huge movie come on like just this
year like what does he need he's been in
like every fast and furious like the
police broke you know there was a whole
thing with yeah I heard about that like
the rock he ended up saying yes to a
spin-off of The Fast and Furious chain
and then so that delayed the last fest
in the various movie and so the Tyrese
is like oh thanks for making it all
about you Dwayne yeah he's saying that
Hugh the rock is breaking up the family
yeah you know the family like we were
all offered spin-offs but Dwayne
accepted it and like turning out his
backs on us but yeah that was drama with
the fascinator stuff there are their
family in the movies and their family in
real life - how was he broke he has so
much because he had the Starbucks that
had McDonald's in his house does one
know it doesn't know I'm not sure about
the McDonald's I'm exactly about that
but he's a Starbucks in his house oh
wait he has a Starbucks in it how
franchise it's a [ __ ] house yeah no
he does straight up a lot of celebrities
have that and they have their barista
that comes in and they just they're just
they're like eight hours a day okay well
they got bad taste because what the [ __ ]
out of all the coffee shop you're gonna
get a Starbucks what the [ __ ] the only
one with the celebrity program you know
that makes me mad I am claiming that
will gave a money if he ends up hosting
this other video here oh no there's more
and it's in a fur coat now I feel bad
for this guy here we go I know I'm going
broke and waiting on my Will Smith wired
and came in yet
waiting on the wire
on a jet go fly to Atlanta girl kiss
your lands bottom today in supporting a
politician vote for if you don't live in
the city Atlanta so we had the whole
point of this video those him saying
like my will wire hasn't came through
and so but I'm about to fly on his jet
yeah why would will wire that money
after all this so TMZ has claimed that
they have spoken to Will and Jada
Pinkett people and that they said that
they have never offered that amount of
money and that they don't know why
Tyrese is making this claim but that
they well of course you're gonna say
that but it's it's highly possible that
they were gonna wire the money but if
they if they were asked they're trying
to stay away from the drama so that's of
course what they're saying but that's
that's like Will Smith's fall you don't
give money to a crazy person like what's
wrong with you I'm gonna [ __ ] Chloe I
crazy crazy I kind of get it though
because they probably feel responsible
as a community if another Asian [ __ ] did
some stupid [ __ ] and they were making
the rest of us look bad I would do it I
would kill them and I'm just like man
feel what the [ __ ] are you doing man
I'll meet up with you gonna be like
you'll feel I got a thousand bucks right
now
[Laughter]
we're talking about realistic levels
alright live in your old car out there
okay I'll be like I feel bad taste
you've been embarrassing us you need to
keep your drama yeah to yourself yeah
I'll let you borrow David's car for a
whole month
cuz you always wanted if you live in it
I can live it you can yeah I'll give you
a thousand bucks and you can eat bananas
for a weekend I'll throw these in every
week I don't finish these bananas and
you just come to Jacob you news it and
all
I want your help if something crazy
don't you have like an extra room in
your house yeah but I use it thank you
man all I'm saying is I got your back
cuz I come through alright when people
are in trouble I come through I'll show
I'll post a picture of me on the phone
with you and be look look Joe's talking
to me he sent me great as they offer
much money it's much money yeah it's
like stop making the community look bad
dude just keep your job what's gonna
happen now well we shall see
yeah we will see well I don't we'll see
this so that they did drop the case
against Tyrese like the whole abuse case
that has been dropped yeah I'm not sure
if he'll be able to see his daughter
anytime soon it's so stupid though like
this is like it's like I said it's hard
I feel sympathy because he's not the
only celebrity that goes to this kind of
stuff they all go a little crazy like
this but at the same time they're so
living beyond so far past their means
like I'm loving it get on this jet real
quick you know seeing this I like just
remove the fact things of celebrity
remove the fact that you posted it on
social media just look at this man
this father like he's like an idiot
because he's not with his child no but
you can't do because you're wearing a
fur coat as your complaint about you
going broke I'm going with this so is
that I sympathize with him like I felt
bad for him because when my parents are
going through a divorce my dad ended up
going through something like this like
similar where he even went to the
hospital because he couldn't eat like we
were apart and like that really does
effectively vlog in in a mansion
I know it's ways that remove it but
that's hard it's hard to remove context
yeah those things make up the situation
see that because I know like a lot like
you mentioned a lot of people in
Hollywood kind of go through these these
meltdowns and it you kind of have to ask
the question like what the [ __ ] is
really happening behind the doors that
we are completely unaware of are you
saying you got Kevin Spacey
no I mean there's like a lot of [ __ ]
that happens behind you know just like
there's a lot of stuff that happens
behind at YouTube JK news cameras I've
been feel waiting before
[Laughter]
[Music]